[Music]
well hello dear friends uh Welcome to
our question and answer program I'd like
to know this is a program where you send
us your questions and we have the
opportunity to do research and attempt
to answer those questions from the Bible
and from the spirit of Prophecy we're so
glad that you decided to join us today
we have some very interesting questions
uh there are so many questions that come
in that uh we have never heard before
and they lead us to really do research
in order to find answers to the
questions uh I want to give you the
electronic address it'll be on the
screen where you can send your questions
TV at sutv
.org once again TVM
tv.org we'd be delighted to get your
questions I have with me Pastor David
Salazar uh he is the CEO of our Spanish
work here at Secrets unsealed among many
other things at this ministry we do all
kinds of things right we don't have just
one job we have many jobs but uh it's a
real blessing to have you with us uh for
your knowledge and also for your will
willingness to abide by our mission amen
and by our message praise the Lord we're
all on the same page praise the Lord
amen Pastor thank you for allowing to be
with you is always an honor a privilege
to share this space this time to discuss
research and answer questions so we pray
will help people to seek and know the
truth praise the lord well we want to
have prayer before we begin we always do
that so would you pray for us please
absolutely let us pray heavenly father
that we uh
come before you this moment we know Lord
that we are unworthy to receive the
knowledge of your word and to uh truly
be able to answer questions that are
many times beyond our understanding but
we thank you for allowing us to have the
gift of the holy spirit that can lead us
into all truth that can teach us and to
remind us of the things that you have
said so we ask humbly at this moment
that you will send the holy spirit so
that Pastor Bora and myself May be able
to share from your word and from your
spirit prophecy the answers that will
give Clarity and understanding to those
that have sent the questions we thank
you for this program we pray that it
will be will be a blessing to those that
are watching and we pray all of this in
Jesus name amen
amen okay we have a very interesting
question um one that I've never seen
before yeah but that's nothing new we
received all kinds of questions that's
right um this question question says
someone told me of a quote by Ellen G
white that I wasn't sure
existed he essentially said the father
told Jesus to not engage in conversation
with Satan he was just to use it is
written is there a quote like this that
exists if Jesus only used it is written
so should we so how do we answer this
question a very interesting question
well certainly pastor this is a question
that um makes made me try to seek for
that quote I really couldn't find a
quote that specifically said that the
father told Jesus not to engage or speak
with the Enemy but what we do know is
that Christ mentioned when he had this
argument or no argument this
confrontation with the enemy in the
temptation at the very beginning of his
ministry we know that Christ the only
thing he said instead of discussing or
entering enter into arguments the only
thing that he said to the enemy at every
Temptation at every attack of the enemy
was it is Gren for example when the
enemy came to him and he was hungry and
he said if thou be the Son of God
command that this Stones be made bread
in verse four of Matthew 4 it says it is
Gritten Jesus answered man shall not
live by bread alone by by every word
that proceeded out of the mouth of God
and then again when he came again with
the second Temptation Christ answered to
him and said it is written again Thou
shalt not tempt the Lord thy God and
then again the third time that he comes
and tries to persuade or to tempt Christ
he did not enter into discussion he did
not enter into argument or reason he
actually said again get the hands Satan
for it is written Thou shalt Worship the
Lord thy God and him only Thou shalt
serve so so he is again using it is grit
as the way to respond to the Temptations
of Satan to the to the the snares of the
enemy and if he set that example we
should follow the same I believe that we
are not to engage with the enemy in
trying to argue or reason but we need to
just say it is written I think that's
the safe you know uh it's a safety for
us if we follow Christ examples amen
there are a couple of places in the
Bible
where uh Jesus refused to argue with
Satan right uh and I want to read those
two statements uh actually the one in
Jude n draws on the one from Zechariah
Chapter 3 right uh but Zechariah
3:1 says then he showed me Joshua the
high priest standing before the angel of
the Lord and Satan standing at his right
hand to oppose him mhm so Joshua is the
high priest is's a symbol of Christ and
uh and Satan is present there to oppose
him he wants to get into an argument but
it says in verse two and the Lord said
to Satan the Lord rebuke you Satan the
Lord who has chosen Jerusalem rebuke you
is this not a brand plucked from the
fire so he's he's not saying I rebuke
you he said the Lord rebukes you and
something similar uh in uh Judah n it's
even stronger there uh in Jude 9 it says
Yet Michael the Archangel in contending
with the devil when he disputed about
the body of Moses dared not bring
against him a reviling accusation in
other words he's wasn't going to get an
argument he wasn't going to accuse him
uh but said the Lord rebuke you so Jesus
left everything in the hands of his
father when he quoted it is written he
was quoting the word of his father uh
and and it's significant that Ellen
White states that in the first two
Temptations Satan presented himself as
an angel of Light right yeah uh you know
he Ellen White comments in selected
messages volume one uh that the devil
came and said you know I heard that an
there's an angel that fell from heaven
and you in this condition you sure look
like that you're that Fallen Angel but
if you're not turn these stones into
bread quite captivating Temptation um
but uh when the third Temptation came
Ellen White says that Satan presented
himself for whom he was he he said I'm
Satan I'll give you the kingdoms of the
world if you just Bow Down and Worship
me uh so these two texts from Zechariah
and from Jude n clearly indicate that
Jesus does not enter into debates with
the devil yeah he always quotes
scripture and always
uh says that the father rebuke him amen
and I think is an example for us to
follow is a wise example for us to not
engage with those that oppose the truth
in in just Arguments for the sake of
arguments yeah but to truly remain
faithful to the word of God and answer
Temptations or objections with it is
written and leave it to the Lord not to
us to try to persuade somebody I've had
many individuals uh um buy me into
having a debate for example over Sabbath
and Sunday MH I've always refused for
the simple reason that I'm not going to
waste my time arguing with somebody who
doesn't want to know the truth exactly
because the the purpose of debating is
not to discover what God wants them to
believe they already decided what they
believe yeah and they they don't they
know that they're not even going to be
able to convince me so what's the use
absolutely okay uh what is our next
question the next question Pastor comes
from uh a friend we not we don't know
where he's from or where she's from but
this person mentions the following
question why does Paul put the alar of
incense inside the holy of holies in
Hebrews
93-4 in contrast to Exodus in the Holy
place this has been controversial for a
long time and has caused controvers for
centuries people use this to say Bible
is involved
inconsistently certainly Paul knew the
layout perfectly can you find a quote to
comment on this thank you and love
watching you on YouTube and we thank you
for watching our program but question is
about the alar of incense that is
described in Hebrews 9:34 why is it
apparently in this uh person's
understanding that it's not in the Holy
place but is inside the most holy place
what can we say about this pastor
B okay um let's read uh the verses uh
let's read beginning in chapter nine uh
chap verse one through verse 4 it says
the
following verse chapter 9 3 through 4
and after the second Veil The Tabernacle
which is called the holiest of all which
had the golden censor and the Ark of the
Covenant overlaid round about the with
gold wherein was the golden pot that had
mana and Aaron's Rod that bed and the T
and the tables of the Covenant and over
it the carim of Glory Shou in the mercy
seed of which we cannot now speak
particularly okay so verse three tells
us that it's speaking about what's
behind the second Veil yes uh which is
called the holiest of all or the most
holy Place mhm and it says that it had
had the golden
sensor and the Ark of the Covenant so it
leaves it leads uh to the idea that uh
the golden sensor is in the most holy
place when Moses described it as being
in the Holy place right um basically
there are two points that I want to make
regarding this first of all even though
the altar of incense was in the Holy
place it was right in front of the ve
right and embroidered on the veil were
Angels ascending and descending on the
veil and when the high priest entered
and he burned
incense uh with a
fire the smoke of the incense would go
up the veil and over the veil into the
most holy Place into the presence of God
correct so even though the um altar of
incense was in the Holy Place its
orientation was toward the most holy
Place uh because the Bible makes it
clear that uh Christ intercedes right at
the altar of
incense uh in for example in Luke
chapter 1 Zechariah is offering incense
in the Holy place and the people are
outside praying well what's happening is
that the the incense mingled with the
fire is going uh above the veil and into
the most holy place of the sanctuary
into the very presence of God so even
though the physical uh altar of incense
is in the Holy Place its orientation is
to the most holy Place
secondly
Jesus uh is still carrying on the
ministration of the Holy place in the
most holy place because the intercession
in the Holy place did not end when the
high priest entered the most holy place
on the day of atonement correct the
intercession
continued of course until uh the sins uh
of the cleansed Sanctuary were placed on
the head of the scapegoat so the altar
of incense and the sensor that's spoken
of here has a very close connection
right with the most holy besides the
holy place so we should not get all
caught up in the geography and say well
the altar is in the Holy place and
that's where it's anchored
and it has nothing to do with the most
holy place it is related closely with
the most holy place is actually the like
you said the link between the most Hol
the holy and the most holy place is
really the the incense that was pouring
into the presence of God even though he
high priest would not go into the most
holy but once a year the the purpose of
the of the incense which are the symbol
of prayers was to go before the presence
of God continually so it was like you
mentioned Pastor correctly very very
accurately you know it is the one um
Furniture in the Holy place that is
directly linked to the most holy place
as well right praise the Lord yeah so I
hope that this is helpful uh you know
sometimes we get so caught up in the
geography yeah that we forget about
function that's right uh and the
function of the altar of incense of
course is to carry our prayers into the
very presence of God amen amen all right
hopefully that's helpful I believe it
would be uh let's continue with the next
question um this is an interesting
question that I also have not heard
before pastor and and I uh had to read
some research about this but obviously
uh I think we have a good answer for
this one the question comes from a
friend of ours uh which is named tanard
daswa we're don't not sure where this
person is from we would like to
encourage people to let us know where
they're from you know it's nice to know
where where they're writing us but the
question is let's say I borrow someone
money am I supposed to give tithe on
that borrowed money so if she or he
borrows money are we supposed to give
tith of that money that was borrowed
that's an interesting question I've
never heard it before what is your take
I haven't either um you know when you're
borrowing the
money you're going to have to pay it
back right yeah is not real income it's
it's not it's not an increase increase
exactly it's a temporary increase um you
know if you borrow the money and that
money
produces uh an increase in interest for
example then you would have to pay a
tithe on the interest right or or if you
invested in something and the investment
uh say you buy a house and the house is
worth
$100,000 later a year later well you
have to tie the $100,000 but but not the
principle that you borrowed because
you're going to have to pay that back
right that's not really an increase an
increase is what you invest your money
in if it produces an increase then you
would tie the increase and if some
someone for example lends you money and
they pardon you the the money the loan
somebody forgives you the loan then it
becomes income and you then could pay or
should pay TI of that absolutely because
it's your it's increased right it's
increase okay it makes perfect sense and
we want to encourage people not to
really get in debt uh obviously we need
to try to be very wise in how we use
money or how we look for something that
we need and we need to get a debt so be
very careful in not really getting to
thatt amen
yes all right uh we have another
question and that comes from the
Philippines from
Ferdinand and uh this is a question that
he's asking us about it says I am fand
from the Philippines my question is I
know that God is composed of three
persons and that God wants an intimate
relationship with us I'd like to know if
we can talk to the three persons of the
godhead separately namely to the father
Jesus and the holy spirit thank you for
accommodating my question God bless so
is an interesting question can we speak
to the three
individually um I don't think there is
well Pastor let you answer but you know
I would say this I believe the Bible
teaches us that we are you know to speak
to God which is the godhead to the
father to the Son and the Holy Spirit in
the prayer of Christ Jesus said you know
we address the prayer to the father but
we submit it in Christ's name and so I
believe that we are to speak in that way
and not to try to just speak to one or
the other it seems like they would be SE
separated but they're one in purpose one
in in in in you know ideal in yeah in
purpose for us well Jesus taught us how
to pray right you know in the master
prayer yeah the greatest prayer ever
prayed Jesus said this is the way you
should pray Our Father which art in
heaven right he also says whatever you
ask of the father in my
name he will do right so we address the
father
in the Name of Christ that's the way to
do it you know there's no place in the
Bible that says we're supposed to pray
to the Holy
Spirit you know some people say oh you
know I prayed to the Holy Spirit no we
need to do it the way the Bible says
we're supposed to do it we address the
father and we at the end of the prayer
we present the name of Jesus because
because the father listens to Jesus
right no one comes to the father Jesus
said but by me mhm and so uh we need to
do it the way the Bible says amen amen
there is this actually verse in U you
know in in well you mentioned no one
comes to the father by me that's found
in John 14 and yet Christ mentions there
you know that if we if we've seen Christ
speaking to the disciples if you've seen
me you see the father so he connects him
to the father continually he's one with
the father there is nothing that Christ
spoke of
himself that the father did not speak to
him so why would we want to speak to the
father separately from Christ if they're
all together they're always in the same
purpose the same ideas the same concepts
for us and then Christ mentions that the
Holy Spirit would be sent so that he can
be in
us and work in our hearts so if Christ
has sent the Holy Spirit to be in our
minds in our lives to speak to us to our
conscious
uh you know they are all together
there's no need for us to pray
individually or try to seek answers
they're not going to give you a
different answer it's not like you need
to ask the father one thing and the
son's GNA give you another answer
they're all in Harmony and the me and
the way to speak to them as you
mentioned I think is the example of
Christ we address the father and I think
it's very important that we always
address the father in our prayer that's
the way that Lord wants us to do and we
finish submitting everything in the Name
of Christ as you have mentioned so yeah
and Paul says in Romans chapter 8 he
says we don't know what to pray for yeah
that's why we need the Holy Spirit the
Holy Spirit who knows right what we
should pray and how we should pray helps
us amen uh so but we don't pray to the
Holy Spirit we pray to the father in The
Name of Christ and the Holy Spirit
through the ministration of the Angels
takes our prayer yeah and brings back
the responses to our prayers and we see
that in the case for example example in
Daniel 8 um where um Daniel 9 actually
where Gabriel Daniel is praying yes and
Gabriel comes back to answer his prayer
he says you know when you began to pray
I was already on my
way praise the Lord God works in in a
wonderful way for his children there is
probably time for one question that is
interesting and is more of a comment I
think they want us from from us that's
from nagor Samuel and it says how can we
assist ourselves from being conformed to
the world through compromising some of
our pillars of faith through cultural
and modern Norms what do you think about
this pastor what can we say to our
friend neor
Samuel the
battle is one or
lost by what we allow to come through
our five
senses bottom line yeah um we are
influenced by what we expose our mind to
and of course what comes into our mind
is what comes through our five senses
you know our sight our hearing our touch
our taste uh Etc right and so we need to
guard what Ellen White calls The Avenues
to the soul which are the five senses
you know if we're if we're watching
television all the time and you know
we're watching the Superbowl commercials
and you know we're we're watching these
uh talk show
and everything you know we're going to
be enculturated if you please by what
we're watching and what we're hearing
right if we're in the word we're going
to stick to the word no matter what
culture dictates uh and of course in
first John chapter 2 yeah uh in verses
15-
17 uh we have God's counsel right uh 1
John
chapter do you have that I have it you
want me to read for 15
uh read 1 John Chapter 2 and vers uh 15
to 17 it says love not the world neither
the things that are in the world if any
man love the world the love of the
father is not in him for all that is in
the world the lust of the Flesh and the
lust of the eyes and the pride of life
is not of the father but is of the world
and the world passed away and the last
off but he that doeth the will of God
abide
forever uh quite an interesting uh verse
that last one yes which says the world
is passing away yes so why would you
want to conform to the world if the
world is passing
away that means you're going to pass
away too absolutely you're going to die
you're GNA be so so the council here is
absolutely explicit we cannot allow the
world to mold what we do and what we say
and you know we we adapt ourselves so
much to the world the music of the world
the entertainment of the world the dress
of the world the food of the world you
know we're so exposed to that constantly
and we're not in the word we're not
meditating on the Lord we're not praying
yes so what can we expect we're molded
according to the world instead of to the
word of God Amen I want to just finish
with this verse in Romans 12:2 that says
be not conformed to this world but be ye
renewed by the renewing by be
transformed rather by the renewing of
your mind that you may prove what is
good and acceptable and perfect will of
God yep that's uh that's the secret uh
so uh focus on that which edifies your
character amen and disdain that which
would conform you to the world well uh
time has passed by very quickly we thank
you so much for having joined us today
for a program I'd like to know please
send us your questions and we hope to
see you at our next program of I'd like
to know God
bless
[Music]